der sommer und die das badewetter sind
noch nicht viele wochen alt der
ereigneten sich in deutschland schon
viele tragische badeunfälle wir fassen
die aktuellen ereignisse einmal zusammen
schon wieder ist ein kind nach einem
badeunfall gestorben
es ist die elfjährige familien aus
nordrhein westfalen
sie galt als gute schwimmerin am freitag
um kurz nach 20 uhr fährt sie mit ihrer
freundin zum adolf wo sie im kreis
heinsberg als die elfjährige alleine ins
wasser geht wartet ihre freundin am ufer
weil sie nicht schwimmen kann dann muss
sie nicht schwimmerin das drama mit
ansehen
fabienne verliert augenscheinlich den
halt und geriet unter wasser weil sich
zu diesem zeitpunkt keine weiteren
personen in der nähe befinden will die
freundin mit ihrem fahrrad hilfe holen
währenddessen treffen zwei spaziergänger
am unfallort ein
bemerken den im wasser treibenden körper
sie alarmieren sofort den rettungsdienst
doch die hilfe kommt zu spät
fabian stirbt im krankenhaus doch wie
kommt es zu der häufung dieser schweren
badeunfälle kinder können in zurzeit
nicht mehr schwimmen weil die schwimmer
aus bildung aufgrund der hain
schließungen nicht mehr gegeben ist
wir vermuten aber dass es mehr unfälle
geben wird weil die leute auf wilde
badestellen ausreichen die nicht bewacht
sind und der schwarze bade sommer 2020
hat noch mehr opfer gefordert
der fünfundzwanzigste juni 22 jährige
werden leblos in einem gartenteich
entdeckt sie waren aufs
nachbargrundstück gelaufen sind dort
dann im teich ertrunken im krankenhaus
kämpfen die ärzte zunächst noch um das
leben der trainings geschwister
vergeblich 27 juni im hessischen tibor
geht bush mit freundinnen und kindern am
rheinufer spazieren
plötzlich ist ihr fünfjähriger sohn
mehmet im rhein
die fünffache mutter springt hinterher
versucht ihren jungen zu retten aber die
strömung ist zu stark beide ertrinken 28
c juni in bayern ertrinkt ein
81-jähriger
als er mit seiner frau in einem see
schwimmen ist feuerwehr taucher finden
den mann schließlich auf dem grund des
sees
ebenfalls am 28 juni stirbt ein
48-jähriger nach dem sprung in die tram
29 juni in schleswig-holstein ertrinken
drei rentner an einem tag zwei frauen in
badeseen ein mann in der nordsee in
allen drei fällen kommt für die
schwimmer jede hilfe zu spät
am selben tag fällt in burladingen in
baden württemberg die vierjährige ursula
in den pool der nachbarn und stirbt
später an den folgen des awa stoff
mangels erster juli ahrenshoop auf dem
darß dort stirbt am mittwoch ein vater
in der ostsee nachdem er zuvor zwei
kinder aus dem wasser gerettet hatte
dabei wird matt idee selbst von der
strömung weggerissen und erst nach
stundenlanger suche tot im wasser
aufgefunden
der familienausflug wird zum alptraum
zurück bleibt seine zehnjährige tochter
seine freundin susi und ihr sohn um
solche badeunfälle zu vermeiden sollte
man folgendes unbedingt beachten wenn
wir baden etwas raten dürfen und können
dann sollte es so sein dass die nicht
versuchen den see zu überqueren sondern
sollten am ufer lang schwimmen dann
sollten sie die baderegeln einhalten und
sie sollten probieren nicht mit alkohol
und dem wasser in kontakt zu kommen das
geht meistens schief
eine bitte wäre noch dass die sich an
den uferbereichen befindlichen personen
dem risiko nicht so aussetzen damit auch
die retter nicht gefährdet sind
das wird immer so ein bisschen hinten
angestellt denn wenn wir eingreifen
müssen aufgrund der infektionsgefahr
gefährden sie auch unser retter und zu
diesem wichtigen thema sprechen wir in
unserer 12 uhr ausgabe mit
schwimmlegende franziska von almsick mit
ihrer eigenen stiftung versucht sie
kinder schwimmen sicherer zu machen
wie das geht und warum das so wichtig
ist klären wir in der 12 uhr sendung